Did I hear someone in
that prior panel say,
if you're against toxic maximalism,
you're against Bitcoin and
you're against freedom?
Yeah, that's some bullshit.
We got 'em warmed up.
Few figures in the Bitcoin community,
are as controversial and
visionary as Erik Voorhees,
founder and CEO of the
cryptocurrency exchange ShapeShift.
He drew cheers and occasional
boos at Bitcoin 2021,
the recent blockbuster
conference in Miami.
Back when cryptocurrency
was in its infancy,
Voorhees was helping to popularize
Bitcoin's unique attributes
with an unregulated online
casino called SatoshiDICE.
After he sold, Voorhees
was investigated by the SEC
and paid a $50,000 fine.
Observing that the
investigators didn't even
seem to understand Bitcoin,
"As much as I hated government
before," he recalled,
"then I was like, 'Man, this
is what these people do,
"'go around ruining
innocent people's lives.'"
Unlike Bitcoin maximalists,
who insist that Bitcoin
is the only cryptocurrency
with any viable future,
Voorhees maintains that other
coins do serve a purpose.
I love seeing all the crypto
projects coming together
with the financial institutions.
I think some people in
crypto don't like that,
but I see crypto taking over the world
and that doesn't happen without
bringing basically everyone into the tent.
In 2017 as fees on the
network were climbing,
he controversially backed
an unsuccessful attempt
to scale up Bitcoin's ability
to process transactions,
which critics said would have
weakened the network security
and decentralized structure.
At the Bitcoin 2021 conference in Miami,
Voorhees talked to Reason
about the immense growth,
not just in the market
caps of cryptocurrencies,
but in their economic
and cultural legitimacy,
the ways in which they
challenged central banks
and political power,
and why he believes in multiple coins and
continuing innovation in digital currency.